sa loi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si côté cette histoire de bye bye bye
sur wat je ne dirai jamais de la
confidentialité
c'est positif ou non sénégal
alors que j'en parle c'est négatif je
suis rarement porteurs demandent
je me dégoûter les magnétos sur vous
alors une méchante méchant pique nique
moda mais les connais mes chaussures au
sommet de la cen sad et régulière
sur les dossiers
beignets
le droit non mais je te jure
il a agréé pour faire piéger sur le toit
du captain me siffler
ses positions c'est le genre combien
ahmed 70,73 ouais ouais
il chausse du 46 mais non non non
thurman 45 non je jure 43
à de mettre
en place une proposition vous n'aimez
pas si j'adore n'a pas l'air pas mal
c'est bien parce que je sais que c'est
peut-être que tu manques en grandir je
ne veux pas faire c'est vrai c'est
chelou d'avoir des bacchanales s'est pas
tu as quel âge maintenant que ces
conneries cinq ans ça va attaquer
aujourd'hui non pas du tout aujourd'hui
j'ai vu un médecin
mais quatre jours
avec 90
des petits et mignons des noms mais
c'est mal
et tout ce qui est grand
calme-toi tout cas tu es tu as beaucoup
de répartie ça fait plaisir
certaines personnes d'avoir misé sur toi
tu désolé franchement servent à la
taille en effet pour un prochain moi je
trouve magnifique où ils seraient payés
en moins c'est bien ce qui inquiète et
bientôt un
[Rires]
fou une claque à tout le métier
évolue on le sait très bon
voila j'ai alors si c'est l'école de
l'animation dinars et on a formé les
plus grands anciens après partir tf1 il
faisait beau tout ça
mais si on a formé les plus grands
amateurs de demain participants
de leur moyenne le cast a dit oui il ya
du de rire by naim via del cid
à l'égard des gens qui veulent un
système
très sympa merci en tout cas au panel
[Applaudissements]
merci à nos
jours c'est l'école
école va nous dire qu'est-ce qu'il va y
avoir dans sa chronique dans ma
chronique oui vent ça aux
téléspectateurs alors on vient dans un
instant
[Rires]
tout de suite il ya du dossier sur cyril
et ya quelqu'un qui est parti en sucette
complètement ça va [ __ ] un bordel pas
possible dans l'émission aulas ces
termes je vous jure que c'est bien vous
doit y avoir une très grosse embrouille
bonne école
alors tu étais koala il est 19 heures 16
oui est-ce que c'est l'heure de gagner
un peu d'oseille cours ambitieux mais
alors c'est la pub nous et maintenant
pas
ce que vous voulez c'est lui qui
écoutent mois d'août pour l'instant oui
t'as combat de magnéto j'en ai ren mois
que
trois cas l'état l'a 4 pourquoi tu as
deux numéros prête à la date de colbert
genre que tu as plus de choses que tu
bien
la même chose pour faire genre non il a
trois
mois pour faire genre j'ai atterri près
par les bleus mais mes frères je connais
bien je vous connaissez pas la télé
merci m regardez les fiches derrière
comme scolaire parce que je suis
professionnel moi oui oui au cas où on
bascule dans tpm p
[Applaudissements]
merci
ah
[Applaudissements]
la la
là c'est pas aidé la mère poule tout
métier voilà il a fait très fort
soudorgues de location
etc la téloche ça s'apprend comme ça
à
partir de la barrière
mais là c'est fou et que là comme on dit
tu m'a cloué le bec
non mais c'est vrai c'est malheureux
qu'on prend des petits trucs là oui
encore turenne m christy walton tout au
bout de mon espace
santé mon jeu wii mais bien des thèmes à
partir de la
forme sourd d'une oreille sur
sa carrosserie fernique enfants
l'américain
s'est
tu vas leur maître il faut commencer par
ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est très bien on va rappeler la
séquence
ayant enfreint femme spéciale fin
d'année on verra comme cette séquence
avec les american staff on plateau qui
viendront témoigner et toute la famille
nicolas pernikoff voilà je vous le dis
semaine pour quelques jours mais la
séquence
comme il est professionnel et en plus ça
va faire une transition avec mon prof
sur magnéto c'est tout ce que vous voyez
à la télé pendant les formes et le
magnéto penser que cyril fait quoi là
pendant des magnétos regardé c'était
avec nicolas pernikoff il était un peu
ému sur l'american staff parce qu'il
nous racontait une histoire
voilà il était il avait ému tout le
plateau révoltez vous voulez mais c'est
au niveau mauvaise foi on est calme toi
ton émotions de trail tu vois bien
compris mais de tuer un chien je parle
la chaîne que je connais la voilà j'ai
acheté ma moi aussi ça je sais d'où il
vient après aujourd'hui les american
staff en train de les mélanger les uns
avec les autres
dépassés sais pas si il a eu peur il a
sauté sur un truc mais tu ne peux pas
aller à la mairie pour le fait que c'est
un chien qui ne risquez rien nicolas ça
vous fait marrer l'appui qu'ils
n'encaissent la fema cette femme à rio
donc ça fait mal
c'est
justement du lot justement en parlant de
cet extrait est bien au bout ça permet
de voir ce qui se passe pendant les pubs
pendant les faits pendant les magnétos
eh bien je sais pas ce qui vous arrive
cyril en ce moment si c'est les beaux
jours les succès d'audience l'argent qui
coule à flot
et en roue libre en cette fin de saison
c'est le perturbateur de classe va
l'apprendre en attendant nicolas
se rappelle que l'agencé européenne elle
est beaucoup moins catégorique alors tu
peux te fier à la chaise quand on sait
qu'à
[Rires]
[Musique]
laisser
quatre heures 5 heures ou 18 heures mais
bram plus tard à plus tard avant les
transports en commun plus tard
tu as dit quelque chose marche et c'est
le vaccin
effectivement voilà la marianne l'égard
de baisse alors
de mettre une chronique yahoo de oud ou
de mac os
c'est de bowling
billard est de lui poser des questions
quand même aussi il faut pas le nier
imprègne de faux billets à faux billets
oui il ya eu des milliers bah oui
gratte-moi les boulistes ont
prendre une branlée aux élections - vous
étiez intelligent vous n'avez pas besoin
de prendre une branlée aux élections
pour ne pas les gens m'aiment olé ola
donc les vacances c'est fait pour se
requinquer se refaire une santé
je suis une bête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n'importe quoi qui s'ébattent en avant
ben oui c'est laid pour les
téléspectateurs qui ne seraient pas au
courant on est très content pour game
j'entends puisqu'il va animer la
matinale de virgin radio à la rentrée
oui on vous l'avait annoncé dans
l'émission mais alors nous on est
content mais je m'adresse directement
avoue benjamin castaldi est ce que vous
êtes content pour votre collègue
guillaume jean torrent très sympa vous
êtes content très content et bien je
vous rends sauze la question dans un
instant après
[Musique]
c'est le retour du jeu qui va partir en
sucette sur la table est un
jeu de ça va partir en sucette sur la
tête de tata changer un maire jacques
gasser
[Musique]
pourquoi il a été question un moment
d'un accessoire magonty par le bas
[Musique]
si al araj aussi un rouge
tuez pas le prendre avec toi mon équipe
ses valets tombe à plat cet aspect
vraiment ignoble non je ne serai pas le
respect des anciens en fait moi
c'est un vignoble bouffe joris faire une
émission cali n'est pas du tout beau et
pas du tout
focaliser les gants sam yom le beauf qui
pète et qui rote ça me débecte
[Applaudissements]
on
voulait faire une personne c'est beau
chic et contador vous voyez pas que
c'est pas moi qui parle c'est un petit
doute mais voilà
non ça ne donne pas en fait
vous savez je me fais un point d'honneur
d'abord aucune répartie et de moins en
arriver et c'est bon personnage ça m'a
fait beaucoup de peine quand même ce
qu'il vient de dire non mais ça va mal
se passer quand on n'a rien à dire quand
on n'a rien à dire on ferme sa gueule au
québec
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi ajouter comme ça par un thé
connard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cypher
en fait tu m'attaques équipe à lui à
tenir
et
ça se voit
louga
quoi
alors merci oui on parle guillaume
genton l'a vu que c'était un fouteur de
merde mais pas au point auquel vous
pensez cyril puisque rappelez vous
quelqu'un qu'on invite souvent dans
l'émission qui s'appelle gilles aussi
prenez ce que vous dites
le meilleur ami de gilles verdez comment
il s'appelle gilles favard exactement à
chaque fois qu'il vient sur plateau
l'impression que les deux vont stop mais
la dernière fois que falloir est venu on
était à deux doigts parce que c'était
particulièrement violent mais qu'il a
chauffé à votre ami pas moi c'est le
blondinet qu'il assurait
on a créé une séquence et là vous allez
voir le nom vous à dire ça c'est la
téloche ça s'appelle la fin var
[Musique]
des fonctions
et regardez moi cette raclure ce petit
bâtard de guillaume valable lui souffler
les punchline pendant la pub rature
jamais
bientôt je comprends pas j'ai 70 ans
j'ai jamais tests sur steam d'air et
tout photo et vient de m'écrire cg qui
connaît
[Applaudissements]
fatou julien dray te rencontrer à 21h15
après l'émission
c'est fatou je sais pas
sans hésiter
à téléphoner à ton ami là tu sais si
saab est bété comme
[Rires]
la même baisse des prix
il a dit qu'il était partant sur le
département il a sur trois ans mais là
c'est certain ben oui tu as la même
baisse depuis 12 ans
m
salut ma couille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est vraiment méchant ça tu veux pas
que fait ça pour attirer son attention
gilles
on amis et tout est moins cher en
difficulté en ce moment et moi je prends
des heures après remonté le moral tu vas
me faire défoncer par fars c'est vrai
mais vraiment météo le pire des
hypocrites
l'info il s'agit non pas qu'on vous
appelle mais bien sûr et me dire tu es
bien reçu non mais t'inquiète pas tu
sais tu t'es je vais te dire la vie
c'est que des déceptions mais n'oublie
gérer ça et je vais dire j'en ai vécu
deux maps qui vous êtes déçu mais
qu'elle
m'avait déçu un jour ou l'autre un jour
à chaque fois vous m'avez demandé des
augmentations
voilà tout simplement voilà delphine oui
ça va toi y en a tant déçu par vos
réponses
j'étais déçu en premier la question le
film allez vous devoir à delphine jamais
jamais elle m'a déçu un jour
c'est très bien ce qu'elle a fait
là c'est on arrête avec ça toute cette
monde on n'en parle plus d'elle fine les
comptes de guillaume genton ah oui
l'amoureux de vous il voulait construire
avec vous j'aurais pu construire avec un
mec comme ça non mais je pense que
depuis la déception qu'il a eue
justement il est différent aujourd'hui
ça l'a rendu méchant c'est vrai parce
qu'avant et emma thompson cahier décrit
alors dans une deuxième vie pour y avoir
une aventure et guillon nantes dans une
troisième dit oui
elle a déjà question
lui ça sera la troisième fois et égale
le papa 104e via
dubaï tu vois ya roger première bille
cellule avant de repartir pour ceux qui
étaient pas là dans l'émission d'hier on
se bat antoine de maximy de j'irai
dormir chez elle dans l'attenté d'en
faire un petit concept gérer ken chez
vous avec daniel moreau qui est allé
chez guillaume genton elle a fait de
très belles rencontres rappelez vous
[Musique]
bienvenue chez lui aux gens qui entrent
et comme chez vous donc je visite là je
suis seulement gelé couvre la sienne de
20 la salle de bain c'est bien celle de
guillaume 500 évident d un petit massage
sa part m
aller parce que j'ai beaucoup donné donc
j'avais japonais a dit annick et chez
didier bourdon
commercial de maxime
[Applaudissements]
c'est la partie visible lisible
c'est tout c'est vous le savez vous
aussi à la maison daniel est une vraie
baraque à frites ans et elle a prouvé
encore hier regarder
choquée
dans la douche
bon ces quatre
[Musique]
suspects
ne sont pas possibles
ces nobles
comme ils s'appellent vous et moi on est
des fois ça passe rien il s'appelle
franck n'ont jusque là pas s'entraîner
tu vas nous demande est là
[Applaudissements]
ces gros personne
mais ça va mon chéri sans merci alors
on était toutes émoustillées ouais je
sais ouais ouais j'étais content mais je
suis boulanger
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore coup là mais tu peux y avait des
baguettes comme astro qu'il tirait torse
nu j'adore ce jour c'est vrai alors mais
c'est pour ça qu'il est rien
sympa
qu'est ce que tu as eue tic daniel a
flashé sur toi je la comprends ouais
est-ce que c'est réciproque aujourd'hui
c'est réciproque oui
je suis célibataire non jure c'est vrai
ça tombe bien les bosses et
je pense vraiment qu'aujourd'hui si je
dois te rapprocher de daniel féau vite
reste daniel énormément énormément
courtisé n'ont ni ses vraies attentes
d'années la france avait en plus il est
sympathique ouais trésor meetic c'est
vrai on a on a eu un bon feeling alors
vous organisez un petit dîner tous les
honneurs mais le pauvre il est tout
jeune
mais s'il est là on s'entend mais
accroche ou pas ouais durable un petit
cadeau oui ouais ben hammam un petit
cadeau ah ouais bah je sais pas ce qui
est
[Applaudissements]
plus rapide l'aquifère pour la ola
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo pour les chouquettes
chez boulanger la chaîne
tu t'es survie connus d'u10 thomas
dernier bah oui oui je suis connu comme
j'ai été pris mais je sens chez lui il y
aura mathieu on organise un grand voyage
c'est sûr alors pour le coup ça
boulanger sera une première ah oui ah
oui c'est vrai c'est pas le corps de
métiers qui se nomme basse est pas allé
aux répondu vraiment mais j'ai toujours
cette même j'adore compris mais
je dirais on peut améliorer c'est vrai
on sait pas mais on peut aimer la
baguette et ont raison
dans la vie
[Rires]
tu viens pour une fougasse et
bah oui et c'est comme ça l'a dit la vie
c'est comme ça la déchetterie quoi tu va
repartir je suis en tout cas il est très
sympa ta vraie ça c'est l'essentiel
ouais bon non mais vraiment oui c'est
une sortie à wil essentielle aujourd'hui
oui oui oui oui enfin c'est d'avoir une
vie mais je crois bien qu'ils puissent y
tu reviens quand tu veux tu reviens
futur est
le bienvenu ici je te le dis merci au
plaisir et et un amour voilà
c'est très 2 messahel
prince tenté par me connaissent que par
royan chez pratiquement que les plus
regardées par la gauche ou pas du tout
mais ça pas du tout je connais très bien
les boulangers les boulangers sont
éclectiques
j'adore mais j'adore les deux mois je
vous dis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m